you put a tweet out about the uh
pandering and posturing that companies
are doing in the west versus what
they're doing in the middle east what
did you learn there
yeah so i mean
uh you know i thought it was quite
interesting because
uh you can tell whether a belief is
genuine by what people are willing to
sacrifice for it
and uh corporations love to appear
compassionate by claiming to stand for
black lives matter or gay pride or
trance rights
but they only openly support these
rights in countries in which they're
already popular
they're not willing to
risk or sacrifice anything for their
professed beliefs and the reason for
this is that their beliefs are just a
charade
so really the point here is just that
words are cheap you know so if you
really want to know if a person's
principles are genuine
see what it actually cost them if it's
cost them something then it's probably a
genuine belief but if it's cost them
nothing
then it's just noise and we see a lot of
that today you know in this kind of
image-oriented age in which we live um
where corporations feel the need to be
part of the conversation and they're
constantly putting out these opinions
that they think are going to be popular
but it's all just it's just a show you
know so i just wanted to draw attention
to that
we see
so much june 1st is like the um twitter
up profile
update photo
collage
deployment
waterfall thing where cisco mercedes
lenovo bmw bethesda
visa bp and millions others that we
probably haven't got screenshots of have
decided to have their
central account with the colours of the
rainbow we're supporting pride we're in
support of gay people around the world
and then the middle east version hasn't
been updated at all i was trying to come
up with a name for it and i was thinking
of something like equality shadow boxing
because that's kind of like what they're
doing they're yeah they're fighting in
an arena that where the
concept's already been won corporations
support pride in the west where it's
widely accepted but not in the east
because their activism is not motivated
by principles but by public relations so
fighting where the battle has already
been won and not fighting for equality
where it's needed
yes absolutely i mean if i had to use a
word to describe it i would just call it
pandering um really you know a nice
simple word because that's essentially
what it is they're they're looking at
their target audience and they're saying
what does this audience want and
at the moment corporations really want
to pull in the sort of tick-tock teens
because they want to get people when
they're young they want to establish you
know brand loyalty to these kids when
they're young so that they'll sort of
stay with them for life and so
um
the tick tock generation is kind of
quite infamous for being quite woke and
you know into all this kind of like uh
sort of social justice posturing
and
as a result of that i think that's why
they've chosen this route they're chosen
to go
towards the more kind of you know social
justice kind of thing you don't really
see corporations sort of being based you
know being you know sort of pro sort of
trump or whatever you know i mean you've
got elon musk who's a very rare
exception he's kind of gone towards the
base group
but i think
he i think hit that's him as an
individual tesla is not doing that you
know tesla is sort of quite still quite
on the left sort of
probably desperately trying to hold on
to whatever uh acceptable face that they
can and wrangling working their way kind
of around elon is this he's a bit of a
force to be reckoned with on his own but
yeah i mean we see this with um body
positivity
websites that are using plus sized girls
and some use plus size guys but for the
most part you don't ever see skinny fat
guys right that are pale that look like
they spend a ton of time in vr okay so
it's it's not about bodies of all sizes
and making everybody feel represented
it's about pushing a narrative that
drives more clicks and means that you
can say we are part of the virtuous
crowd you do not need to look here over
there those are the people that aren't
doing it uh i mean you see it with the
the different races that are used as
well a lot of them i mean asos is really
bad for this tons and tons of their
models are now mixed-race guys that have
got neck tattoos but there's no asians
there's basically no asians on that site
and you go well okay like
what is it that you're doing it's it's
split testing something that
mediates between
we need to be able to show variety and
signal virtue and we still need to drive
clicks so all of that's been split
tested as well if fat asian lads
were selling more asos clothes do you
not think that they would be using it um
exactly yeah
i mean you know i don't see a problem
with sort of
diversifying sort of models and things
like that i think it's okay but i think
the issue
begins when
there's
when it's basically sort of done
performatively and an example of this is
um in i think there's this i don't
really watch star wars so i don't know
much about it but i saw this tweet
recently um in which the star wars
official account
basically posted their new actress who's
going to be like a main star of one of
their upcoming shows or something i
don't i don't really know what it is but
it was a black woman and the tweet was
essentially saying like this is our new
um star she's a black woman she's a
strong independent black woman and they
were really like highlighting the fact
that she's black you know and they were
like you know if you have a problem with
her then we don't want you um to be one
of our fans you know it was a very sort
of confrontational tweet and i was like
i don't understand the point in it
because if you look at the previous the
old star wars i mean i haven't really
seen much but i remember the originals
and there's that lando calrissian is a
black guy there's no mention is made of
this guy being a black guy because he
doesn't it doesn't need to be made the
point doesn't need to be made that he's
a black guy he you know it doesn't
matter that he's a black guy so
people didn't have a problem with that
and it's when they start
forcefully saying you know this is our
main star and this is a black guy or a
black woman and you you you will enjoy
it or you will you know suffer the
consequences sort of thing yeah that's i
think that's it's a very aggressive kind
of
thing that i think a lot turns a lot of
people off but also it also turns a lot
of people on unfortunately as well which
is why they do it
if we make it all the way to whatever
your star wars is set in and we've got
lightsabers and laser guns and we can
travel super super fast around the
universe and yet still the most
important thing about somebody is their
skin color i honestly think just bring
on the death star man [ __ ] send us
all send us all to the end of hell
because
i don't want to live in that future
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
you